okay let's talk about policy for a
moment we talk about Trump scandals on
the David Pakman show we are under no
false pretenses that it is anything but
constant scandal under the Donald Trump
administration constant political
abortions constant vile actions constant
embarrassing events to the United States
of America perpetrated by our president
and his cronies but we can't ignore that
a lot of those scandals can sometimes
provide cover for really horrible things
that Republicans are doing and one of
those things that Republicans just did
this week is yet another vulture
capitalist gift to major corporations in
the middle of the night very late
Tuesday early Wednesday call it what you
want the Senate voted 50/50 to give
major immunity against lawsuits to not
daycare providers not social nonprofits
not some other type of company or
industry known for doing really great
things for lots of people but providing
lawsuit immunity to credit card
companies car lenders and companies like
Equifax and other financial firms but
hold on a second David you said that
they voted 50/50 so it didn't pass right
well when the Senate votes 50/50 the
vice president gets to vote to break the
tie and our buddy
hardcore religious right ideologue Mike
Pence broke the tie in the Senate and
the House approved that as well and
Donald Trump is expected to sign it so
what are the details there is or I guess
soon we'll be saying there was a rule
from the Consumer Financial Protection
Bureau that stops or stopped lots of
financial firms from doing two things
that are not good for the average
consumer
number one it forced arbitration
agreements or companies would try to
force arbitration agreements where
companies wouldn't do business with
consumers who wouldn't sign away the
right to sue the company in a real court
so the Consumer Financial Protection
Bureau put in place a rule which said
hey businesses you can't make people
preemptively say we will never sue you
you can't do that
and the other thing that the CFPB rules
did was prohibit credit card companies
and many other financial firms from
requiring consumers to sign away their
right to bring class-action lawsuits
because even if you are not suing
someone in court in the way that part
one of this require vents you could
still conceivably be part of bringing a
class-action lawsuit and you were
signing away your right to do that the
CFPB prevented companies from forcing
you to do that those rules are being
eliminated this is a huge huge win for
the banking industry for the financial
services industry and why should be
worried right I mean why should anyone
ever be in the position of having to sue
one of these companies right oh wait a
second Equifax just had a major security
breach which compromised the data of
hundreds of millions of Americans and
most of you whose data was held by
Equifax didn't choose to do business
with Equifax as a credit reporting
Bureau Equifax has your data even if you
have never provided it to Equifax or as
far as you know you've never done
business with Equifax and there's a sort
of logistical question that I'm getting
from a couple people on this which is
okay fine David this is bad but if it
was 50/50 in the Senate why are you
pointing the finger at Republicans for
the fact that this was passed we'll hold
on a second every Democrat in the Senate
voted to keep the rules that we had and
two Republicans also voted to keep the
rules that we had Lindsey Graham and
John Kennedy every other Republican
voted to scrap the rules which got them
to 50 votes and then Mike Pence broke
broke the tie the term in play here is
called regulatory capture okay if you've
ever taken a an undergraduate economics
class you probably have heard the term
regulatory capture you've taken
political science classes you may have
heard the term regulatory capture means
a regulatory agency that is supposedly
there to protect you right to protect
consumers they end up advancing the
interests and the priorities of the
corporations that they are supposed to
be regulating very often at Urich's
Bent's right at the expense of consumers
that they are supposedly meant to
protect I go back to Equifax Equifax had
this major security breach it is the
consumers who should be increasingly
protected from companies like Equifax
and their wrongdoing or negligence or
neglect
but instead what this law change will do
is it will protect Equifax from being
sued by people like you and me and us
participating or bringing class-action
lawsuits and again we have no choice but
to do business with Equifax because they
are a credit reporting Bureau so the
entire both parties are the same thing
I'm the first to tell you that on many
issues both Democrats and Republicans by
and large are the same but there are
many issues where there are major
differences and if anyone still thinks
both parties are the same you've stopped
paying attention a long time ago that is
one of the most tired talking points
another version of that talking point is
when you point to corruption or you
point to whatever right both sides do it
and I see both sides false balance I
mean it's logically fallacious and I'm
talking about in casual conversations
people write to me they say David I want
to better know how to debate politics
with people in my life don't fall for
false balance where you have these
supposed fair arbiters of politics who
like to present themselves as objective
when they say hey listen I recognize
that both sides do ABCD whatever
sometimes that's true and sometimes it's
not so don't fall for that red herring
when you're talking to someone and they
try to get out of a conversation out of
defending whoever it is they voted for
by saying both sides do it anyway
discussion about this on our reddit
discussion forum david pakman.com slash
re d di t join us there we'll take a
break back after this today's program is
made possible in part by Gamefly which
is sort of like netflix for video games
they've got over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can also stream games you don't even
need a gaming console or a computer
because you can stream games through
your Amazon
firestick or Roku box and then use your
mobile phone as the controller you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low used price never with due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
30-day free trial at Gamefly offer.com
slash TDP s the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included no contracts and you can also
stream the games I think I mentioned
that you can also rent games through the
mobile app get a free 30-day trial for
david pakman show viewers and listeners
and support our show at Gamefly
offer.com forward slash TDP s